the only way to fight a virus that knows
no borders is to fight it globally this
is why the EU has started Team Europe a
twenty billion euro package to combine
resources by the EU and its member
states to support countries in
particular in Africa and the EU s
neighborhood but also Asia and the
Pacific as well as Latin America and the
Caribbean the majority of the investment
comes from pre-existing programs the
rest is from Member States contributions
and financial institutions this is of
course about European solidarity but for
me it's about human solidarity we need
to do whatever we can now to save lives
and of course this virus because
otherwise as you repeat we will see a
second way and a third way in Europe the
chairs of the parliamentary committees
on Development Foreign Affairs and
budget have come together to plead for a
global covert 19 fight and have
highlighted the importance of
international cooperation with partner
countries the EU aid to fight the
coronavirus alongside third countries
has three aims respond to the immediate
health crisis by supporting response
plans strengthen health water and
sanitation systems to help partner
countries face the crisis and mitigate
the social and economic consequences by
supporting small and medium enterprises
Parliament has welcomed the IMF decision
to provide debt relief to poorer
countries and called on other
international donors to take similar
measures ma Pease stress it is vital to
address the economic and social impact
of the virus around the world not just
at home
[Music]
you